you see people that can't sleep don't
sleep for one major reason because as
their environment quiets their mind
wakes up right so most of you will lay
that have to have insomnia you will lay
down tired right you lay in bed tired
and your mind turns on and now it's your
mind keeping you awake it's not that
your body's not tired and why does your
mind keep you awake well because just
like we create
thought we also dismantle thought human
beings actually create thought and
there's a gene called SE om Mt compt
stands for catacol Oyl transferase you
don't need to know that I just want you
to know I'm smart it's called comp te we
can test for this gene mutation if you
have this gene mutation you lack an
essential amino acid called el
methionine when aling goes up into the
mind it allows your body to break down
thought and quiet the mind